tant directs nicolas sarkozy sait qu'il
fait peur moi peut-être même à lui-même
de temps en temps quand il se regarde
oui il sait qu'il fait peur qu'il
inquiète et que nul n'est vraiment
complètement rassuré peut-être même
jusque dans son propre camp
mais alors pour ne pas inquiéter pas
alarmer pas alerter nous sommes dans un
temps de communication depuis le cyber
et de fossa qui était de rien ayez
confiance j'ai changé et est rejeté la
droite décomplexée
aujourd'hui je suis un président sans
complexe je parle à tout le monde je
vais dans les cantines je rencontre des
ouvriers
je vois les agriculteurs et puis je
cours je cours sans cesse je cours
encore jeu pour toujours
là on est devant le morceau d'éloquence
enfin je pense que on retrouve un peu le
personnage de françois hollande qui
s'est effectivement assez bien manier la
langue qu'il ya quelque chose parfois de
d'humoristique enfin il ya un côté
humour danse a dans sa façon de
présenter les choses
il ya un côté évidemment outre et on est
dans un meeting politique c'est vrai
qu'être une série de reproches qui sont
faits au président par contre il ya des
traits qui sont assez spécifique de
hollande cette espèce d'humour un peu
plus raffiné consistant à dire il a peur
de lui même quand il se regarde dans la
glace ou des choses comme ça là on
retrouve un peu ce personnage dans
l'humour et quelquefois même pas perçu
par les gens parce que c'est quelque
fois un numéro au second degré ça c'est
trop subtil pour être perçu parfois à
mon avis les meilleurs moments de
françois hollande ce sont les mêmes
moments subtil qui sont quand même temps
pas toujours les mieux perçue par
l'opinion sérieux il ya un côté chez lui
deux assez acide en fait même parfois
assez cruel dans sa manière de porter
comme ça des traits d'humour et on
retient plutôt de lui le côté plutôt
lisse plus tôt auront plutôt donc moi je
pense qu'il ya un côté un peu double
chez lui la droite ne veut pas être la
droite on peut la comprendre
nicolas sarkozy n'est plus de l'ump nous
dit il il est 2 france
il aurait pu dire de neuilly nord il est
de france là on a un très bel exemple de
du type de communication de françois
hollande à il est magnifique et dans un
rôle de conteur une raconte une histoire
et le voilà d'ailleurs qui vient
chercher dans notre propre histoire ses
références jaurès blum
mitterrand c'est à dire qu'il va y avoir
trois ou quatre fois de suite le même
scénario en fait jusqu'au point
culminant qui est sarkozy aurait quand
même pu citer jusqu'à c'est du repos
jusqu'à d'avoir mitterrand comme
référence mais ça c'est magnifique c'est
vraiment c'est vraiment la structure du
compte et en fait c'est un conteur
mettez vous un peu à sa place
vous seriez de droite ce que vous n'êtes
pas j'en conviens vous seriez de droite
mais qui chercheriez vous comme
référence de gaulle sûrement mais avant
de gaulle après de gaulle qui alors il
ya une part là aussi de spécialisation
des fonctions dans un cas comme ça le
candidat rassemble et le premier
secrétaire quand ce n'est pas lui qui
candidat de premier secrétaire
attaque et se faire que rem une
spécialité de l'offensé politique bon et
là il faut reconnaître que c'est assez
cruel c'est d'ailleurs historiquement
assez rapide aussi mais ça il le fait
exprès puis c'est de la polémique même
si c'est vrai que que dans l'histoire de
tous les pays du monde les grandes
avancées sociales ont été bien sûr c'est
le travail de ces ça a été la saison été
faite par ap par la gauche mais
il faut pas perdre une élection et
surtout moi j'ai l'impression toujours
ce qui me tue avec la gauche française
c'est que la gauche française elle est
qu'avant convaincu qu'elle a raison
tout simplement parce qu'elle est la
gauche française oui c'est un peu ce
qu'ils il ad'ailleurs et ça ne suffit
plus et quand vous dites là françois
hollande il est arrogant pourquoi parce
qu'ils se moquent ces mots que le
sarkozy sarkozy
moi je pense pas que les électeurs même
si peut-être sur le fond il a raison
mais je pense pas que si c'est une
tactique efficace
je pense que l'électeur n'est pas n'est
pas dupe je pense que les lecteurs voit
très bien que si le parti socialiste et
le chef du parti socialiste si le seul
moyen moyen qu'ils trouvent pour contrer
sarkozy c'est de se moquer unis je pense
que à la limite c'est contre-productif
gagner des élections il faut convaincre
des électeurs pas des militants des
militants sont déjà convaincu les
téléspectateurs n'aime pas ceux qui
prennent des positions violentes
violence symbolique mais ceux qui
il n'aime pas ceux qui sont agressifs
ils n'aiment pas ceux qui fabriquent des
clivages des les téléspectateurs si
j'ose dire sont comme nicolas sarkozy et
ségolène royal dire que ils rêvent que
de toute façon à l'arrivée il ya un
rassemblement
d'ailleurs on voit très bien quand on
prend la liste des gens qui sont les
plus populaires ce sont toujours les
plus consensuels qui sont les plus
populaires c'est pas un hasard il lui a
fait un aveu j'ai changé at il dit
retenez bien cette expression
s'il a changé ce qui n'était pas bien
avant
et s'il a changé ce qu'il sera pas mieux
après tout que c'est efficace sous ses
pas efficace mais les meetings c'est si
on venait pas de la cuisine de secondes
quand il est là françois il est surtout
là pour galvaniser son propre parti ses
propres militants et pour emmener des
foules militante vers sa fin vers les
mois et les semaines de campagne qui
vont être long et donc il est là pour
être l'une des parties à la première
partie du spectacle
il sait très bien que le soir ce qui
sera repris ce serait essentiellement
liste de ségolène sur son pacte
présidentiel donc il le fait en même
temps est ce qu'il est mais il va y sera
pour utilité
et quelque chose à la fois intéressant
et peut-être un peu de prémonitoire dans
ce document ségolène royal fait son
entrée habituel durant cette campagne
qu'une chanson on l'a fait sur mesure
tout pour célébrer la gamme la dame
madame ségolène royal est finalement un
françois hollande qui est à la tribune
qui embrasse zapatero et qui s'éclipse
il se profile entre guillemets et eux
mêmes ne se croisent pas ne parle pas
n'apparaissent pas ensemble absolument
et il apparaît presque comme un monsieur
loyal
à défaut d'être sur royal
la chaîne ary ja camarades merci d'abord
de l'inviter chez ségolène royal salue
bien volontiers regard de notre réunion
avec beaucoup d'attention
il ya une parole amusé il ya quelque
chose qui fait rire dans cette façon
dead de faire allusion à l'accueil de
ségolène qui est de la ségolène absente
et en même temps il ya quelque chose qui
projetait au niveau médiatique fait
ressortir alors à ce moment-là l'absence
là c'est plutôt quelqu'un qui s'amusent
de la situation et qui venant
effectivement chez des proches de
ségolène royal s'amuse avec eux mais
c'est pas on n'y a pas je ne crois pas
que françois dans ses relations avec
ségolène il ya un moment ou un autre
l'envy de grincer ou de passer des
messages par la télévision qui soit
autre que ce
quelqu'un qui s'amusait situation mais
vous dites il s'amuse de la situation
mais de quelle situation et s'il s'est
beaucoup amusé du fait qu'il était le
monsieur de la dame
et pendant que la campagne électorale
c'est vrai qu'il y avait une situation
un peu particulière puisque pour la
première fois on avait un premier
secrétaire qui était aussi à la ville le
compagnon de la cognette à la
présidentielle intéressant surtout la
postaillerie c'est qu'il met le doigt
sur le fait qu'ils font pas campagne
ensemble finalement rue mais c'est assez
normal il est le premier secrétaire elle
est la candidate
franchement c'est elle qui est la
candidate et et lui il ne peut faire que
de l'accompagnement
il est il est un contrepoint utile tant
que concernant ségolène royal c'est
plutôt un humour bienveillant qui fait
apparaître c'est pas du tout c'est pas
distancié vis-à-vis d'elles s'est
distanciée vis-à-vis de lui mais il est
toujours distancié vis-à-vis de lui et 2
qui il a un humour qui le submerge
je dirais même qui quelquefois le
handicap mais loi qui on dirait que je
vous dis il ne peut pas s'empêcher
d'être lucide et comme il est de nature
caustique
quand il est lucide ne peut pas
s'empêcher de le dire de façon drôle
ce qui fait que les gens comprennent
encore plus facilement il a un côté
intrigant lors des vingt écoutez moi
toujours un peu mystérieuse qu'il a une
manière de présenter les choses avec
cette septième en grinçant qui met en
évidence comme une sorte de décalage
permanence c'est comme un comique un peu
décalé on a l'impression que c'est un
rire qui qui qui suscite en fait des
interrogations
c'est pas le c'est pas le rire franc
c'est le rire un peu angoissant
finalement par rapport à ce personnage
qui se couple ce couple décalé aussi
qu'on a vu se produire en permanence
alors qu'on pouvait se dire au départ on
pouvait se dire c'est un couple donc en
fait il l'a toujours soutenu
c'est tout a été justement comploté en
sorte qu'elle soit la candidate et qu'il
soit son plus fidèle lieutenant bat pas
du tout ça c'est pas du tout passé comme
ça on va parler en disant c'est pas du
tout le message qu'il envoie il fait
percevoir le fait qu'ils aient dit
qu'ils sont par moments dans de ce faire
il ya la ségosphère et puis il ya
solférino nous devons nous rassembler
d'abord rassembler la banque traces de
pas le plus facile de rassembler la
gauche
ce serait tellement mieux s'il n'y avait
que les socialistes à gauche encore que
quand on connaît les socialistes ça ça
notre respect assez typique de françois
hollande
et on voit sur le ps qui l'a il a un
humour assez caustique et on voit qu'il
est très conscient de la situation des
divisions internes et c'est donc le
leitmotiv c'est rassembler la gauche
c'est une sorte d'incantation va
rassembler rassembler rassembler tout le
monde est divisé et tout le monde veut
rassembler mais autour de lui et
françois hollande évidemment en tant que
c'est le gardien du temple c'est lui qui
allait des clés du parti et dont le rôle
est justement de rassembler va avoir
cette incantation perpétuer sa gamme
permis de rester dix ans oui mais ces
critères du père ça lui a permis de
durer
on peut se demander si c'est la bonne
stratégie c'est l'homme de la synthèse
est l'homme du consensus absolument
manifeste mais est ce que c'est la bonne
stratégie pour gagner ça c'est autre
chose
elle n'est pas facile cette gauche ce
serait tellement faim mais s'il n'y
avait que des socialistes
encore que même s'il n'y avait que les
socialistes ça serait pas si simple j'en
ai bien conscience
il peut pas s'empêcher d'une certaine
lucidité et y compris vis-à-vis du ps et
compris vis-à-vis de la gauche à y
compris vis-à-vis de lui-même
alors évidemment quand on est trop
lucide sur soi qui conçoit c'est un peu
paralysant et vous dites ça les
handicaps pourquoi c'est le handicap
contre neutre aux lucides sur soi à un
moment donné en attendant ce un peu à
s'analyser soi même au lieu d'agir et de
prendre des initiatives
je vais commencer par parler de nos
défauts cette propension que nous avons
pour le débat qui va jusqu'à la division
cet amour pour la magie des mots
qui va jusqu'au fiasco des actes parfois
cette mauvaise conscience que nous avons
en permanence et qui peut tourner au
mauvais esprit pour ne pas être assez à
gauche jusqu'au point de jeter la
suspicion sur nous mêmes d'abord c'est
un constat très juste l'historien que je
suis historien et politologue mais
l'historien approuve la gauche en france
comme dans d'autres pays en particulier
l'italie mais la gauche en france est
caractérisé par son sa tendance à se
déchirer à se diviser à scissionner à sa
scissiparité a explosé comme ça en
permanence et c'est une tradition de la
gauche française
on est sur un rassemblement de
sensibilité personnalité et c'est vrai
que c'est jamais simple d'avoir à opérer
ce rassemblement l'a donc fait et je
crois aussi sont à la fois soviétique et
sa croix pendant les essais si dur que
ça de rassembler les socialistes c'est
toujours plus facile de rassembler dans
la victoire
et quand on connaît une défaite comme
celle de 2002 où tous les compteurs sont
remis à zéro
eh bien il faut gérer des personnalités
des ambitions parfois aussi des ego et
donc ça suppose beaucoup de patience et
de diplomatie pour arriver à garder tout
le monde derrière une même bannière
oui chers amis chers camarades
les socialistes sont de retour françois
hollande est devenu le vrai chef de file
du ps
il n'a été dans des conditions
évidemment catastrophique
tout aurait pu sombrer au lendemain de
notre défaite et quelle défaite injuste
qu elle nous aurions pu également
succombé aux surenchères au coeur à elle
aux délices que quelquefois le parti
socialiste a su nourrir en son sein et
parfois même ne pas le digérer
et donc nous avons su surmonter ces
épreuves et engager une réflexion
collective de qualité
il a hérité d'un parti totalement
déstabilisé après un échec politique
politique électorale qui était
gigantesque
et au fond c'est probablement la raison
pour laquelle il ya aussi bien entendu
son tempérament mais c'est probablement
la raison pour laquelle il a en
permanence donner la priorité au
rassemblement à l'unité voire au
consensus
au lendemain de cette terrible défaite
de cette humiliation de ce traumatisme
lionel jospin n'est plus là le nail
jospin n'est plus là donc c'est une des
grandes figures du socialisme qui a pris
sa retraite et évidemment c'est le choc
des ambitions et aussi les affrontements
sur les stratégies à mener
qu'est ce qu'ils essayent de faire
françois hollande il essaye de
reconstituer le parti d'abord l'unité du
parti
c'est incontestable et d'avoir une
politique qui essaye d'expliquer les
raisons de la défaite mais là évidemment
un désaccord il ya ceux qui pensent que
jospin échoué parce qu'ils n'étaient pas
assez à gauche et ceux qui pensent que
justement jose preuve a échoué parce
qu'il n'a pas encore porté jusqu'au bout
la révision de l'ensemble de la
politique du parti socialiste et
françois hollande va essayer de tenir
tout ça ensemble c'est à dire du
réformisme mais aussi à gauche
il est arrivé
et merci jean christophe tout
interrompre et la cgt je suppose
voilà
donne aux invités je suis je ne peux pas
vous dire
the do demande d'applaudir bernard
thibault qui vient de rentrer dans le
concret et voilà que c'est bernard
thibault kitakami
nous sommes en pleine question de la
réforme des retraites et justement c'est
le parti qui passe à gauche si vous
voulez et françois hollande qui est un
fin militants comprend certainement cela
dire qu'il doit à la fois constituer un
parti réformiste de culture de
gouvernement et en même temps répondre à
cette attente de gauche à cette
sensibilité de gauche qui est présente
dans le parti et qui s'est manifesté
encore une fois dans un autre maman de
ce congrès lors du remarquable discours
de laurent fabius qui a enflammé la
salle pour la défense de la liste je
vois ce débat à propos de la future
constitution européenne où certains
proposent sans que cela semble choquer
sauf nouveau heureusement quelques
autres que l'on définisse l'europe parce
affiliation religieuse est en très haut
lieu
qu'est-ce qu'on répond à tout cela il
faut faire preuve de sagesse qui ne font
rien busqué qu'il faut voir les
problèmes au cas par cas
eh bien nous socialistes nous disons que
la république ne se défend pas au cas
par cas
on a l'impression que françois hollande
ait conduit d'ailleurs à la sortie
puristes soulagé on est très soulagés
il reconstitue le parti il est à sa tête
il peut peut-être avoir des espoirs mis
là dans la chronologie qu les échéances
électorales de 2004 et en 2004 y gagne
pourquoi pas penser plus loin c'est
certainement ce qu'il se pose comme
question
et vous pensez qu'à ce moment là il se
voit lui candidat je ne sais pas s'il se
voit candidat mais je ne vois pas
pourquoi il ne s'opposerait pas à cette
question c'est quand même la logique
vous êtes premier secrétaire du
principal parti d'opposition
jusqu'ici tous les premiers secrétaires
ont été candidats tout le monde est
d'accord pour le fait que vous dirigez
sur le fait que vous dirigez ce parti
c'est normal que dans le système de la
vème république vous pensiez à une
candidature du comme des affrontements
assez récurrent est assez violente
socialiste il faut se rappeler le
référendum interne du ps sur le traité
constitutionnel européen puis le
référendum externe nationale qui a alors
encore vu s'affronter une partie de la
gauche avec une partie du ps avec autre
partie du ps puis le congrès du mans qui
a fini par une synthèse et mais québec
commandent commencer par par
l'opposition assez fort entre les
différentes sensibilités du ps
voilà le premier secrétaire de tous les
socialistes qui arrive
chaque fois c'est vrai qu'il a réussi à
mettre tout le monde d'accord comment il
a fait pour réussir la synthèse c'est
quoi sa recette
françois c'est pas l'homme d'une
ambition personnelle c'est pas l'homme
d'un clan et donc il a toujours cherché
à faire prévaloir l'intérêt général du
parti socialiste et donc on peut
reprocher beaucoup de choses mais il a
toujours réussi parce qu'il y avait un
comportement personnel et quittez pas
celui d'un homme de clan à réconcilier
les différentes parties en présence et à
les amener à discuter ensemble et puis à
trouver le mot du juge lundi pour les
années qui suivent est bon maintenant la
difficulté du ps pendant ces années là
c'est que et c'est ce qui rend les
choses très compliquées pour un premier
secrétaire c'est que personne ne veut
tellement majorité et donc on est dans
une situation où au fond chacun dispose
de 20 25 % du ps et chaque fois que le
premier fait mouvement les deux suivants
où les trois suivants cherche à le
bloquer pour éviter que quelqu'un prenne
davantage de manière durable et donc
une situation qui en interdisait aussi
au premier secrétaire d'avancé
exactement comme ils entendent s est pas
on est loin des règles intérieures avec
des blocs qui sont beaucoup plus
homogène est beaucoup plus élevée qui
permettait au premier secrétaire d'avoir
les coudées plus franches donc chez
françois y avait aussi une obligation
qui était sol de trouver aussi le
compromis pour pouvoir faire avancer le
ps quel est le bon moment
non aussi j'ai réfléchi et j'ai beaucoup
consulté nos manuels d'histoire interne
enfin c'était le centenaire c'est normal
qu est la plus belle élection que nous
ayons gagné présidentielle mai 1981
françois mitterrand il ya eu une
deuxième en phase iv pas eu la première
je crois pas qu'ils auraient eu la
deuxième dont c'est la plus belle 80
quand est ce que françois mitterrand a
été candidat a annoncé sa candidature
novembre 1980 et bien je vous suggère
françois mitterrand n'étant pas le plus
malhabile d'entre nous le plus beau des
stratèges et le moins bon de nos
candidats je vous suggère de reprendre
le même calendrier qui nous a fait
gagner au mai 1981 il faut pas faire la
comparaison avec françois mitterrand
françois mitterrand depuis 1965 et
surtout après 74 et est le chef de la
gauche en france
il était acceptée contesté par michel
rocard à la droite et ses cheveux de moi
là à la gauche
on va toujours monsieur je fais de mon
là mais on savait le psv la france avec
à françois mitterrand allait être le
candidat en fait fast food on arrive
2005 6 même début 2007 et personnes
vraiment été prêt quand le ps a accepté
un seul candidat
on avait élu françois lang énorme
remarquable très apprécié par la gauche
en europe mais tout de suite il aida
dans son bureau de première secrétaire
et on entend les éléphants frappant à la
porte frappe olavide frappe au dessus
frappe aux dents bas en dix ans nous
ouah ouah il était incapable d'accepter
qu'un l'idée de primus end par sk un ou
une soeur est ce un deux trois ans avant
l'élection pas six mois avant l'élection
et qui soit acceptée comme le leader
pour le parti pour gagner et n'ayez
aucune inquiétude
même si certains ne l'ont pas
quant à la floraison des candidats ou
des candidates nous verrons le moment
venu je suis sûr qu'il y en aura moins
ça se décante seul à faire là
globalement son choix ça d'abord était
celui-là c'est à dire en réalité le
choix d'une sorte d'infirmiers génial du
ps infirmiers parce que c'était même pas
un médecin il combattait la douleur il
essayé de soigner les plaies mais il
guérissait pas le malade et en même
temps génial parce que c'est vrai qu'il
est arrivé à force d'habileté à à tenir
ensemble des forces qui prenait quand
même des positions incroyablement
contradictoires mais est ce que
finalement cette obsession qu'il a eue
de vouloir rassembler le parti a pas a
été finalement en espèce de
un frein à ce qu'ils pouvaient le faire
évoluer c'est pour ça je vous dis qu'en
fait ça plus était un infirmier génial
qu'un médecin efficace il est arrivé à a
obligé les rivaux à se supporter et à
contraindre les factions à vivre
ensemble
donc il a atteint l'objectif qu'ils se
donnaient ici aux morts le message de
notre congrès est limpide simples
évidents et doit être entendu de tous
les socialistes sont désormais tous
rassemblés pour servir la france
et en même temps cet objectif était dans
quelque sorte stérile parce que toutes
les questions que le ps aurait dû se
poser au lieu de les poser on les éviter
qu'est ce qui a permis selon vous
d'imposer sa d'imposer cette synthèse de
savoir faire je pense que c'est
quelqu'un qui est plus habile que les
autres qui a une intelligence politique
plus grande que les autres je dis pas
que ce soit vrai dans tous les domaines
de l'intelligence mais je crois qu'il ya
une vraie intelligence politique que il
avait quand même le statut de sa
fonction qui lui donnait une autorité et
qu' il a été extrêmement malin dans la
façon de montrer à chacun des grands
leaders du ps ayant de grandes ambitions
à quel point l'absence d'accord se
ferait à son détriment
au détriment de fabius au détriment de
strauss kahn au détriment de tout le
monde d'accord donc il leur a laissé
entendre qu'il pourrait être candidat
avec la synthèse les laisser dans la
course en fait et il aura surtout été
laissé entendre à chacun que la synthèse
renforce tout le monde sauf lui ce qui
était vrai coin et ben voilà ça a été
vrai à l'arrivée c'est bien là où je
voulais revenir
il est très sympa moi je la trouve j'ai
toujours trouvé que j'ai rencontré
plusieurs atouts très souvent j'ai
toujours trouvé très sympa et très
intelligent
et très drôle est vraiment un mec très
sympa et peut-être je sais pas juste
trop sympa ou ou pas assez autoritaire
où il n'exerce pas aussi de discipline
et il veut avec un petit peu de dons non
donnons un petit peu de 2 voilà je serai
je serai je ferai en sorte que je serais
aussi haut 6 aussi sympa de possibles je
vais te fais en sorte que ça parce que
pour lui évidemment l'unité c'était ce
qui ce qui compte est donc il est
peut-être prête à lui je viens vu la
synthèse c'est lui qui est l'homme de la
synthèse exactement pour qu'un parti
aujourd'hui je pense puisse réussir il
faut qu'il part avec une seule voie est
le grand problème du ps de demandes
point de vue c'est qu'on a on entend six
ou sept huit ou dix d'ivoire
qu'ils disent parfois la même chose mais
très souvent pas la même chose et
surtout des gens qu'on connaît très bien
je pense qu'il faut que les socialistes
se rassemblent pour travailler ensemble
ce qui compte c'est qu'il ya une
majorité et que donc une direction sur
une orientation
mon idée c'est de rassembler d'arriver à
la plus grande unité possible
oui le véritable enjeu c'est que le
parti socialiste tout entier le parti
socialiste rassemblée s'adresse au pays
il n'ya qu'un seul socialisme c'est
cette unité retrouvée
c'est cette unité retrouvée qui nous
qualifie maintenant pour rassembler
l'ensemble de la gauche autour de nous
au mans par exemple tout le monde se
féliciter et les commentateurs de la
synthèse qu'il avait réussi on avait
l'impression qu'ils en sortent grandis
présidentiable tout le monde en sort
tout le monde d'abord moi j'en suis pas
sorti satisfait le lendemain matin le
lundi matin ici je fais un éditorial en
disant que je trouvais au contraire que
c'était une synthèse qui était
artificielle et qui avait voulu
escamoter les problèmes et beaucoup ont
pensé que du coup ça allait l'aider à
être candidat moi je crois pas parce que
ils avaient neutralisé toutes les
oppositions mais il n'avait pas
renforcer son autorité
il était arrivé à arrondir les angles
il n'était pas arrivé à se sculpter une
statue d'ailleurs la façon dont ségolène
royal a pu démarrer de manière quasi
simultanée sa campagne alors même que l
avait parlé avant qu'elle n'a absolument
pas parlé pendant et puisqu'elle a pu
rebondir après ça prouve bien que le
fait d'avoir mis tout le monde d'accord
finalement ce n'était pas lui que ça
renforçait
tout le monde est gouverné avec tout le
monde il est contre les partis mais il
est pour ancrer à l'autre le chien en
disant qu'il était donné avec des
socialistes
mais les socialistes d'une certaine
espèce d'oiseau il a demandé à de l'or
mais jeunes ce qui était quand même un
peu même pour de l'or l'une des lunes
des questions qu'on peut exploser
mais ça c'est une question et
prospective c'est de savoir quelle était
en fait dans tout cela la pensée de
françois hollande ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire que pour vous il est pas
porteur il ait jamais été porteurs d'un
message politique finalement ça a été un
apparatchik du ps je dirais pas que
c'est seulement seulement un apparatchik
mais en même temps il n'a pas apporté
dans le débat politique
quelque chose dont on puisse dire voilà
quelle était la pensée de françois
hollande voit là soit là quel était le
message de françois hollande s'il a tenu
un message peut-être son message
principal c'était ce message européen
on voudrait écarté nous dit on ce qui
est essentiel dans le traité et qui
porte précisément sur tout ce que nous
avons fait nous les socialistes depuis
1957 ensemble c'est dire le traité de
rome
l'acte unique européen en 1986 le traité
de maastricht en 1992 le traité
d'amsterdam en 1997 et même le traité de
dix ans l'an 2000 tout ce que nous avons
fait ensemble comme socialiste
il faudrait le récuser te d'autre que
des socialistes et cette tentation je
peux les comprendre
à gauche et que des socialistes puis
écarté ce que nous avons fait ensemble
je m'interroge encore sur leurs
motivations il a poussé à ce référendum
on peut dire que il essaie lui même en
quelque sorte piégée alors qu'il était
dans une situation extrêmement favorable
sur le plan personnel et sur le plan de
son leadership
il sait piéger dans cette affaire de
référendum peut être précisément parce
que là il avait une conviction très
forte qu'il fallait faire avancer la
france sur le terrain on perd et là
bizarrement il s'est trouvé décalé par
rapport à ses propres amis
c'est une lourde défaite pour françois
hollande c'est une lourde défaite du
parti socialiste envers l'opinion et ça
affaiblit évidemment la crédibilité de
françois hollande pour la suite donc il
en sort particulièrement à
oui parce que c'est lui qui a voulu tu
ça
alors françois hollande n'est pas là
effectivement de nous on ne voit pas
parmi les les
les invités car françois hollande
interviendra à la fin on a dit des
débats en tant que premier secrétaire et
non pas en tant que candidat potentiel
donc on peut parler de cet intervenant
mais ils ne sont que six arrivées
ensemble donc laurent fabius dominique
strauss kahn jacques landes martine
aubry ségolène royal et lionel jospin
alors beaucoup de copains vous le voyez
sur cette image je voulais du tout à
l'heure il ya pas moins de 400 et puis à
lens ou mois de septembre alors que
justement tous les prétendants devaient
se déclarer lui renonce au dernier
moment
pourquoi vous avez une explication que
je n'ai pas eu d'explication
exceptionnellement inédite le rapport
des forces à ce moment là avait déjà
cristallisé qu'il y avait les partisans
de laurent fabius qui avait des
partisans de jack lang qui avait les
partisans de dominique strauss kahn qui
avait des partisans de lionel jospin bon
et et qui avait la foule des partisans
de ségolène royal mais que comme lui ne
s'était pas vraiment exprimé comme lui
avait laissé le jeu se dérouler sans lui
comme il avait plutôt organiser le jeu
des autres qu'il avait voulu s'y mêler
lui il n'avait pas sa base à ce moment
là et comme c'est un réaliste n'ayant
pas sa base il ne pouvait pas se lancer
en bon en plus il est évident que s'il
se lançait il se lançait contre ségolène
royal croit que c'était totalement
inimaginables à ce moment là il ne
pouvait se lancer dans la course
présidentielle en rivalité avec ségolène
royal qu'à partir du moment où tous les
autres à le lui demander en faisait le
sauveur ils ne lui ont jamais demandé la
parole et à notre premier secrétaire
françois hollande heures
quel bonheur que d'être premier
secrétaire du parti socialiste
d'abord parce que ça me permet de
conclure
il n'ya là d'ailleurs
aucun privilège simplement la récompense
de l'effort
depuis tant d'années j'ai conclu tous
les chantiers du pas de calais celui là
aussi il a toujours eu à la fois
l'ambition personnelle qui est bien
légitime pourquoi serait-il le sol est
parmi les socialistes a refusé d'être un
jour candidat la présence en république
mais en même temps cette volonté de ne
pas handicaper les autres par le choix
personnel qu'il pouvait réaliser et donc
je l'avais vu cent fois à la fois
cherché à trouver la porte qui
permettrait de rentrer là où il fallait
et en même temps préserver les chances
préserver la réputation préservée les
espérances de chacun parce qu'il avait
la volonté de ne desservir aucun moment
l'idéal commun qu'est ce qui manque
alors à françois hollande l'homme est
intelligent c'est incontestable il est
un vrai leader politique
il aurait fait un triomphe sous la
quatrième république un triomphe d'un
vrai parlementaire il a le sens de la
manoeuvre tactique il sait faire du judo
politique qui fait faire des prises à
ses adversaires
or les sondages ne désigne pas françois
hollande comme un candidat cas précis
les gens de gauche où la gauche pourquoi
bien je pense que françois hollande paye
la tripe l'évolution de notre vie
politique des grandes démocraties
occidentales
la personnalisation de plus en plus
marquée il doit apparaître comme un
leader capable de parler à la population
d'être séduisant et ça il a du mal à le
faire deuxième point la
présidentialisation ça signifie choisir
aussi un responsable qui semble crédible
pour occuper une imposante on sait
qu'ils les stratégies et là c'est pas le
problème de la capacité personnelle de
françois hollande ses capacités
intellectuelles qu en cause mais c'est
la terrible impréparation ou en tout cas
la faible préparation de l'ensemble du
parti socialiste sur des questions
absolument clé et puis le troisième
point c'est la médiatisation
la politique est devenue effectivement
un spectacle et si les gens réclament
des stars ils réclament aussi un
politique
donc on peut jouer d'une manière plus ou
moins résonné d'une manière plus ou
moins habiles avec ce phénomène de
starisation
et là ça passe pas pourquoi il n'a pas
cherché où il n'y avait pas les atouts
pour peut-être pas les atouts pour
est-ce qu'il faut incriminer différents
points son physique sa posture banques
c'est terrible
dire parce que ces redoutables mais
c'est comme ça oui il faudra leur
rappeler cette leçon simple que si l'on
veut battre la gauche il y avait qu un
yack avec la gauche pendant si on veut
battre la gauche on peut toujours le
faire
en votant à droite mais si on veut
battre la gauche avec la droite et si on
veut battre la droite
c'est avec la bouche
si hollande avait voulu être candidat il
aurait été obligé de changer aussi
hélas il n'a pas changé il souffre de
son image quelque part ce que ce qui est
très bien enfin moi je préfère ça vous
l'essayez que les images construites
l'archi médiatisé qu'on a vu c'est
l'anti ségolène royal quelque part
ségolène royal était ultra attentive à
son image elle était c'est une image de
letra construisent les journées il s'en
plaignaient même pas ce qu'il pouvait
pas prendre sous de telles en grèce et l
ultra calculé tout était ultra formaté
hollande et s'en fout c'est manifeste y
arriver tout transpirant il est un peu
bedonnant son costume est pas un c'est
que c'est pas jack lang qu'ils fabulent
voyez les autres ils sont impeccables et
élus difficilement sa fille
st
contre nous
pense que nuit il aurait dû partir il ya
cinq ans je pense et je pense que les
autres ont dû partir à 55 ans je pense
qu'après 2002 il y aurait dû avoir un
énorme balayage de tous les éléphants de
tous les gonzes et chez les autres et
jose e échelons du parti socialiste et
que même s'il n'avait pas gagné
ils ont perdu 5 ans en fait il si si si
c'est si ce n'était pas sûr qu'ils
avaient trouvée était passé de tous
qu'ils allaient trouver quelqu'un pour
contrer sarko qui piqua capable de
contrer sarkozy pour 2007
je pense qu'ils seraient dans une bien
meilleure position trop de nous tous
la gauche en france depuis 1981 n'était
jamais exclu de pouvoir totalement
pendant une longue période c'était ils
ont perdu l'assemblée nationale 86 mais
mi temps on était là ils ont perdu la
présidence en 1995 et deux ans plus tard
mais si j'ose pas et est retourné chez
nous on a passé cinq ans et puis disons
et puis 12 ans et à ce moment là deux
ans d'exclusion total de fautes et
ministérielles de pouvoir politique dans
le pays
on parle du leader on se regarder dans
la glace des miroirs en disant non il
faut changer
est ce que cette mobilité arrivé pour la
gauche en france je ne sais pas je pense
que je pense franchement que la personne
qui va faire gagner le ps français on ne
le connaît pas en rond nous on ne
connaît pas encore de la même façon que
d'erika mann qui est tombée on vient en
tête des sondages et qui vraiment
inquiets qui pose un danger sérieux au
gourou brown aux prochaines législatives
en angleterre il ya cinq ans ne savais
pas qui c'était il ya 3 oh vous savez
pas qui c'était ya deux ans on fait on
ne savait pas qui c'était
et je pense qu'il fait il faut juste du
revenu renouvellement mais du
renouvellement autour d'une d'une
compréhension véritable que la
discipline
si on n'aime pas si si on apprécie
l'idéologie si on a apprécié le débat si
on fait de la politique pour en discuter
etc etc on veut faire une différence et
c'est si on est socialiste dans l'âme et
et tous ces arguments
bon et bien bel et bien mais il mais ce
qu'il faut c'est de la discipline c'est
fini les années 80 c'est fini les années
90 c'est fini même le premier parti de
cette décennie
il faut à nouveau ps pour la nouvelle
france qui est en train de se former
est ce qu'il y avait une mission c'est
un truc que le jour où il sera à nouveau
un citoyen ou faisons un parlementaire
parmi d'autres il retrouvera aussi une
forme de liberté moi j'espère qu'il
emploie à dire qu'il est vraiment parce
que pour ceux qui le connaissent et
qu'ils approchent il a une profondeur
que peu lui connaissent et moi j'ai
finalement un seul regret c'est de ces
années passées avec lui c'est qu'il
n'est pas suffisamment souvent révélé sa
vraie personnalité on en a fait quelques
uns de fabre il est au contraire
extrêmement vif on a fait quelques uns
qui étaient uniquement en version de la
synthèse est aussi câble capable d'avoir
une pensée extrêmement tranché et
d'avoir une capacité à comprendre à
saisir le réel plus vite que d'autres à
le comprendre et analyser et à proposer
derrière les solutions qui est qui et
qui sont à mon avis les meilleurs c'est
vrai que peut-être que dans la nouvelle
vie qu'il se prépare il y aura pour lui
cette occasion de présenter un autre
visage
une autre image
un autre notre destin je pense que lui à
lui je pense qu'il a au moins autant de
talent politique que les autres pour
être candidat alors évidemment il peut
pas le fait pas maintenant que ça se
décidera ça se dit sera dans deux ans
dans trois ans et il faut que entre
temps il se reconstruise dans l'opinion
une personnalité non plus de chef de
parti mais deux ténors politiques ayant
vocation à être candidat
autrement dit ça veut dire qu'il faut
qu'ils les ennemis politiques qu'ils
soient pas la résultante des lignes
politiques du ps mais sa ligne politique
qui n'a jamais par exemple en matière
d'alliances
bon ça veut dire surtout qu'il faut
qu'ils aient des idées
hollande on a eu des tactiques hollande
maintenant s'il veut être candidat il
faut des idées hollande qu'on identifie
à une demi douzaine de grandes options
fermement exprimée original et qui
dessine un autre personnage mais vous
pensez que c'est possible justement pour
quelqu'un qui n'a jamais jamais défendu
des idées hollande dans des formes du
jour au lendemain ce qu'il en a tout à
fait l'aptitude intellectuelle il faudra
qu'il en est le il faudra où il faudrait
qu'il en ait le désir ça il ya plus qui
peut le savoir mais je suis sûr que
c'est quelque chose qui ne peut se faire
qu'en plusieurs années et donc qu'il n'a
pas beaucoup de temps pour se décider
paradoxalement s'il veut se construire
une autre personnalité dans l'opinion et
je crois que c'est un préalable pour que
puisse être candidat il faut que s'ils
mettent maintenant
à